from very early on because there wasn't
anything new everything was a
breakthrough so it was kind of easy in
those days to do more stuff nowadays the
young people coming along heaven much
harder because there's a huge body of
work they have to be familiar with I
didn't have to be familiar with anything
except basic economics and statistics in
order to proceed with my work and at
that time the reason all that started at
that time is it's kind of silly because
what started it was the fact that
computers came and computers made it
easy for people to do work with data
that was very difficult to do before
that they had to use these old
mechanical calculators that the people
watching this have probably never seen
in there and their lifetimes and it was
very difficult to do things accurately
even and then computers came they were
not as powerful as your cell phone is is
now but they were a revelation at that
time so all kinds of people got
interested in doing work with computers
and stock prices are one of the most
easily available data that you can get
so lots of people started to work on
stock prices and returns and that's
where I started to